there's so much stuff going on in the
market these days bitcoin dogecoin
shibuyno what should i do nfts stock
market companies tesla elon musk but at
the end of the day the
something that you guys have to focus on
is how much
should you be spending on food and rent
each month
okay right see what i went there with
that there's so much stuff that you can
be focused on but the end of the day the
basic stuff is how much should you be
spending on your eating and living cost
each week i'm sorry each month yeah okay
so nobody likes the budget so i'm going
to budget for you
i'm going to say here i'm going to do
this for you let me tell you so notes
basically let's and we can extrapolate
these numbers you can make a little bit
less you make a little bit more but if
you are making 50 000 a year
nothing crazy not amazing not poor doing
okay
50 grand single person
you know obviously if you're a head of
household married there's that's another
that's another level of things but if
you're making 50 grand a year here's how
much you should be spending
on food and rent each month based on 50k
it's a cnbc story
so let's say you make 50 gs
okay after taxes
you're probably again it's gonna depend
on your state your income this the
bracket state tax this is a very general
thing here so
play along accordingly uh after taxes
you're probably gonna be taking around
taking home around forty thousand
dollars if you're making fifty let's say
your taxes are twenty percent
give or take now you're walking away
with about forty thousand dollars a year
take home pay and if you break that down
that's about 3 300
a month we're getting somewhere right
now so your housing
your housing
the cost should be no more
than 30
of your gross income let's do some basic
math for people at home you're making 50
g's
30 of that is 15 000
15 000 divided by 12 that's how many
months there are a year david okay that
comes out to
1250 dollars
a month of what you can afford in rent
so let's just talk about this for a
little bit if you make 50 gs you should
be again around 30 of gross income
your rent should be somewhere around
twelve thirteen hundred dollars that's
the number max
now if you double that if you're making
a hundred grand
now you can spend
twenty six hundred dollars
a month in rent right right you're
making 200 grand 26 times 2 54. now you
can spend 50 400
in rent see how that works so 30 is the
number if you're making 50 gs keep your
rent somewhat somewhere around 1200
bucks cool
this is your rent bro this is what you
can afford now you know so if you're
spending two grand a month you got it
but you make 50 grand a year
you're done messed up yeah we'll talk
about a budget in a second we have to
find out where that money is that can be
used elsewhere because you're only
making 50 grand that's the number so
question is
where are you at with this and your rent
number two now food
i talk about your big three expenses
which include your housing which we just
talked about your transportation we talk
about cars all the time yeah number
three
is your f and b your food and beverage
this and i talk about your food right
now so your food should be somewhere
around 10
of your total pay 10
okay
so
of your take-home pay let's say you're
making 3 300 bucks a month that's i'm
sorry 30 exactly 3 300 bucks a month 10
of that
a month okay so maybe that's 80 bucks a
week
maybe that's somewhere around there so
you go out and you drop a hundred at the
bar one night
yikes you already used it up for you
you used up a third of your stuff so the
average uh
us household is their monthly groceries
now we're talking groceries here in this
segment
it's just a little under 400 bucks 380
bucks call it 400 bucks so that's about
of their budget right there so
you got to ask yourself okay there's a
difference between groceries and take
and going to the grocery store going to
you know publix down here in florida or
you're going to um
you know woolworths or whatever the hell
you got going on or whether that's whole
foods or whatever it is or whole
paychecks the difference in doing that
versus doing ubereats or doordash you
know or take out delivery
three to five times a week like certain
people we know and there's a difference
between doing that and going to actual
restaurants happy hour eating drinking
eating out that kind of stuff like that
so with your f b it's death by a
thousand bites so ask yourself all right
cool have i ever even done a food budget
all right if i make 50 gs take home pay
300 bucks yeah i kind of need to be
around 400 bucks for the month that's
100 bucks a week in groceries and we'll
talk about all right well if i want to
spend extra on the weekends all right
this is these are numbers that you need
to do yeah this is important because you
know what you're paying in rent
you know what your car payment is it's
kind of fixed these things are kind of
fixed food is the one thing it's just
like i don't know just swipe right swipe
swipe i don't know uh swipe lunch box
after work you want to get beers after
work that's 60 bucks bing bing bing
right this adds up right right so
so let's let's recap real quick yeah
i've been taking notes sauce
billionaire by episode 100. 30
on your housing yes and that's based
around your 3 300 a month that's based
on your total gross income so if you're
50 grand
you know your take on paid 300 yes you
should be spending
um what was it 12.50 exactly right 12.50
a month on housing if you're making 50
gs you're making 50 this is all based
around 50. it's all based around 50 g's
so if you're only making 40 scale it
down a little bit if you're making 80
scale it up this is good stuff this is
good stuff bro this is good stuff oh
yeah oh we go down we're helping the
people now we're going on food that's 10
every total pay for the month so again
yes so we're looking at
330 per month or 100
i'm sorry or 80
per week there you go
now you might be saying this isn't
enough i got to have a little more
flexibility i want to go i don't want to
drink i want everything right all right
let's talk about this there's something
called we've talked about this
let's talk about overall budget now
there's something called the 50 30 20
rule 50 goes to your needs 30 goes to
your wants 20 goes to your financials
savings and debt so let's just do a
quick little calculator
um
if you're making 50 gs
okay 50g now let's talk about overall
budget needs wants financials right okay
50 g's after taxes you're making 40 gs
right what have you 3 300 bucks a month
50 of the 3 300 these are your needs
housing food okay is sixteen hundred
fifty dollars
sixteen fifty so in your needs i need
this my rent i gotta i gotta have
utilities i gotta get the lights on over
here and i would what i would call a
stocked fridge i'm not these aren't this
isn't uber eats this isn't going out to
the club this i got food in the fridge
necessities necessities like this this
is the basics this isn't the sushi the
nice sushi this is like yeah i need some
like meats and cheeses and milk and like
this basic stuff you're at 16.50 okay of
your necessities now 30 can go to your
wants
now what are your wants
um
by the way this is 30 this is 990 so
about a thousand dollars
goes to watts 1650 needs 50
but a little less than a thousand bucks
990 your wants what do you want you want
to go out you want to have a nice time
you want to go to the bar you need a
nice cell phone you want to have so you
know obviously your cell phone bill is
kind of a in between a need and a wall
what type of
you want to go out um you want to buy
new clothes that's every month you got a
thousand bucks like what do i want to do
this month netflix subscriptions taking
a girl on a date buying your man some
flower whatever the hell it is
um these are your ones but 20 and here's
the kicker baby save that money 20 needs
to go to your savings or your financials
are paying off debt that's 660
a month so if you're taking home 3 300
bucks a month based on 50 g's
here are the numbers 50
necessities 16.50 1 650. 30 your wants
990 bucks call it a g that was your
wants financials the key 20
60 bucks stack that cash pay off debt
contribute to your 401k whatever it is
that the key to it all
is having that 20 percent mindset you
see what i'm saying because it's a
puzzle you got to figure it all out how
much am i spending on rent how much am i
spending on food and beverage how much
is my car do i have a car do i have an
uber actually i don't have a car so i'm
just ubering anywhere so i'm saving
money so i can spend a little bit more
on rent all right cool rent's crazy
expensive dude i ain't going out like
it's a puzzle but the 20
mindset is key because you can either
pay yourself first
or you pay yourself last the people that
pay themselves first have proven time
after time to build wealth they're
stacking cash they're putting on the
side they're contributing their 401k
they're investing in their business
whatever it is they're putting that
money away and then they'll live on the
rest of the 80
the people that try to spend first go
out pay their rent have a good time eat
drink and be merry they've got no money
left at the end of the month and then
it's just a cycle it's a vicious cycle
yeah
pay yourself first you've heard that a
million different times but this is like
the real life example of why you need to
pay yourself first put your money aside
invest get it out of there then you
spend what's left see what i'm saying
david for someone who's
somehow
makes somewhere in this ballpark what
did this do for you
well this kind of just puts things in
perspective so i did something similar a
couple of weeks ago where i just tallied
up i was like all right this is how much
i'm getting this month total with all my
paychecks oh it sounds to me like you
did a budget it sounds like a budget
right is that what that's called i don't
know
uh and then i went all right what are
the total expenses of all my bills and i
went down to the tiny nitty gritty
like spotify hulu all these little
things that are just automatic oh yeah
that you miss yes also found a bunch of
that i wasn't using i was paying
like two bucks for like nintendo or
something i was like what the heck
the last time i played get it out get it
out immediately i was like
50 a month on uh sound effects on
something that i don't i no
i don't use
um
so i went through all that and um found
out my exact numbers but this isn't too
far off from like what i got
and so this really again puts gives you
bumpers we're at extreme action park
with a staff meeting and they ask if
they want the bumpers for the bowling
this kind of gives you those bumpers so
when you roll your money down
you keep it in line and you hit a
straight line exactly so this is a lot
this is good this is the the numbers
that people are like all right yeah i
should budget but how much should go to
this how much is too much for my saving
do you know what this is what i talk
about the beginning of every show this
is 50 knowledge 50
behavior knowledge okay maybe i didn't
know these numbers yeah okay now maybe i
didn't know now you know bro right
exactly the more you know now
what are your behaviors are you staying
within that budget are you spending too
much on rent do you need a downsize do
you need to get a roommate can you
actually spend more on rent hey i'm
doing okay oh you know what i actually
don't want to spend that much because i
want to save them i want to want save
that money like
these are the this is what gets me
excited yeah i got to be honest with you
talking about the rate of return of a
certain index fund and the mutual fund
like that's that's not tangible stuff
rent each and every month how much food
you're putting in your stupid face david
this is tangible stuff 100 yeah you have
a beautiful face i'm sorry i don't wanna
i know it's not crazy i'm i'm you know
and this is funny because knowing all
these things and having this plan gives
you that peace of mind right
and so you don't have to worry about oh
my god am i gonna have enough yes i am
because i made that plan already i
already i know exactly where my money's
going and what it's doing so will i have
enough for you know to put gas yes i do
yes i know exactly where that is going
to so this that's one less thing you got
to worry about this is what i'm talking
about this is why i'm here dude i think
i just made a million bucks we're just
saying
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken